press the white button and try the
sniper rifle
[Music]
okay
it's so satisfying right
what's up everybody my name is zaki and
i'm junior and today we got something
special to show you guys this is the
butt kicker gamer plus what is the butt
kicker so essentially what it does is
that it sends haptic feedback or
basically just vibrations through the
chair and up here
nice if i'm not wrong there are other
variants of the butt kicker right yep so
there's also the gamer pro which is a
much larger profile but the game of plus
is a much cheaper option at 279 usd so
us dollars yeah to actually
have vibrations i think
pretty much
and the thing is xeno already had some
time with it and he endorses the hobart
kicker i'm a little bit of a skeptic so
we are gonna see how effective it
actually works it works
so we're gonna walk through the setup
and kitama said you know it's pretty
much plug and play so it's gonna be
relatively easy and we're gonna test it
out on the pc the ps5 and the xbox and
more importantly we're gonna mount it on
our secret chairs yeah and if you're new
to the channel welcome to geek culture
we cover tons of different topics and
different stuff
we do things like entertainment cameras
air fryers everything but the kitchen
sink unless we get the sink of course so
do stick around because you might find
something you like so do subscribe and
give us a like it will help us a lot
that's it before we begin here's a
message from our sponsor
watch it
here at geek culture we love our
keyboards especially with the all new
logitech mx keys mini an elegant and
functional keyboard its ultra responsive
rounded keycaps are super stable and
quiet for more productivity there are
buttons to enable dictation microphone
audio control and emojis the backlit
keys illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or 5 months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com so this is the main
bucket gamer plus unit and inside of
this the moving mess is about 1.2
kilograms or 2.7 pounds in freedom units
so this mechanism here is how it's going
to clamp onto the chair so what we're
gonna do is gonna open it up real quick
this isn't exactly a step by step so
we're gonna have fun with it and move on
i'm gonna clamp the butt kicker on that
portion of the chair so that the haptic
feedback can be sent through this thing
jesus just you know this is our regular
day at the office so we are being very
ourselves right now yeah it's it's
yeah you're going to hear us you know
pretty much swearing
this whole video
but once you get it in there
you kind of look like this
so just screw it on like that
and we have a 9.8 inch cable with quick
release that connects the gamer plus to
the amplifier so in any case like say if
you're using a gaming chair
and you kind of veer off too far away
from the main unit this thing will
release
quickly
this is the amplifier and you don't have
to worry about it overheating because it
has fanless cooling so once you got it
set up just throw it away have you seen
your own desk when you put this have you
seen your desk
damn it
so with the wire splitter down here the
rca cables and a usbc two usb a cable
which comes with the butt kicker pretty
much just plug them in and it's that
easy to set it up so for the y splitter
you're going to connect one end to the
rca cables and the other will be used to
connect to either your headphones or
your speakers the bucket gamer plus and
i think the pro as well also comes with
a remote and of course the power cable
so just plug your headphones or speakers
in and get the other end of the wire
splitter and plug it into your pc or
your sound card i tried using my samba
which is connected to my pc without it
being directly connected to the butt
kicker amplifier and there was a little
bit of input lag on there so if you
really want that full immersion where
it's completely accurate you'll be best
off
directly connecting it into the y
splitter for the bucket clamp okay so
once you have the bucket amplifier set
up and everything what you need to do
next is actually install haptic connect
which is available on the part kicker
website so we'll have to connect you can
actually just change up your settings
and everything for racing games because
we only have one we will need to go for
mono and let's just switch this thing on
so what you're going to do is set up the
audio so the first thing you need to do
is actually go to your settings over
here click that and select the butt
kicker input and then from there you're
going to set the outputs so we have the
headphones real tech usb audio which we
are using as an output let's just try
some music real quick i hope you guys
can hear it hold on
yep
all right so this one this one uh the
the jurassic park this is some
science man we're going to place it here
on our omega lumbar cushion and then
we're going to play some very very heavy
music
you see that with the reflection on the
lights there
oh sorry okay so there was some quick
but yeah science but we're going to
i'm
wow this is like going to a club you're
right
before having to
actually experience it no sweaty bodies
in like yeah
interesting yeah but this huge thing
here take a look
it's like a rc radio yeah
or something okay so it
actually
agitates the actual stem itself yeah
exactly the power of vibration guys
vibrations
so the easiest way to connect your butt
kicker to your console is to take your
controller take the y splitter like we
did with the pc earlier on and just plug
it straight in and in this case we
swapped out the headphones to our
soundbar over here so while you're
playing at the game obviously whether
you're chalking or you're galloping on a
horse you can feel that feedback coming
through the secret lab chair it picks
out the vibration the background music
and even when you request
for help from your mother or your
father's sorry the father is a win
if you do this
you can feel the wind up your butt
i need to try try this out because i
don't believe you see you not one bit
okay jean sakai horsey horsey no i can't
feel the father but i can feel these
people
how's combat like so far i don't know
how to play
what does it feel like when you when you
strike someone
it is strong okay it might be like a
small little motor i'm guessing that's
why there's an amplifier here yeah but
it i think because when you have a
bucket seat it really encapsulates the
vibrations too so you really do feel
like you're immersed so far does it work
it works man
it works pretty well see the lines i
feel it from the tip of my toes to
all right so we got the xbox series x
synced up yep pretty much in the same
way as the playstation but the one thing
i did forget to mention is that if you
don't want to hook up your bucket cut
like this all the time you will need to
buy additional um devices such as a hdmi
extractor or an rca extractor really
sick
oh that's great yeah so far like you
know it picks up on every shot or okay i
don't know it just feels really good the
vehicle
you hear that yeah you can hear it
revving you can feel it rapping also
so we have debbie down here who's our
second guinea pig
right oh my god
oh my god like it really feels like
you're like sitting on the chair right
it feels like you're sitting in the
vehicle yeah okay wait baby press the
white button and try the sniper
okay i've got to rifle
sick right
i love it
[Music]
it's so satisfying right
all right xeno so the butt kicker gamer
plus
let's just start with you first yeah so
the thing is i like the idea of having
haptic feedback for my gameplay when i'm
playing fps's or you know even watching
movies or listening to music because it
does give me that extra sense of
immersion it does make me feel like i'm
actually actively part of the media i am
partaking in wow very english today
no i think i i have the same sentiments
because like it does play out very
differently from what you feel in your
hands like there's just
a level one yeah you know and then when
you have the whole immersion that you're
both your control especially when it
comes to consoles yeah exactly the
controller and the haptic feedback
coming from your seat
does make a lot of difference all right
so xeno ultimately it boils down to this
question give me a gimmick
surprisingly i'd say it's actually more
of a gimmick
aside from the product you know it's a
good product right it's one of those
things where you know if i had a bit
more cash on hand i just like oh they
found this thing sounds cool
and have money
so why not just try it out you gotta
have a real good vested interest
when it comes to these products again we
are not
punching down it is a great product it's
good it's just would you buy it is it
really for you you know it's not
mediocre it's not lackluster it's
full-on
honestly it gets noisy yeah so it's it's
quite funny because
like we were just sitting here for
headphones right and xenos on his
headphones he had a bucket go on playing
whatever music he was playing
and all you can hear right it's just him
groaning
and the seat vibrating
was there any caveats for you because
like yeah the issues i faced with the
bucket so far is that even though it's
plug and play it's a bit more than that
sometimes because like when i set it up
for the first time during my initial
test run like it was okay but then
subsequently every time i try to i
change the source and everything it just
ends up not working even though the
settings are the same yeah and you know
that you just don't want to have bias
remotes you can get it and then you
realize you're not using it you know
because then again also you know that's
quite a bit of setup i mean the setup is
easy yes but there's a lot of wires you
know you think through about cable
management anything and i know a lot of
you out there like your minimalist
setups and anything you're not like me
or zeki i mean if you've seen these
jesus christ alright so that covers the
review of the butt kicker gamer plus we
hope you guys enjoyed it yeah but
obviously you know this is our unit that
we reviewed i've seen a lot of other
videos out there and the thing is
they've enjoyed using their unit so take
our opinions with a pinch of salt and if
you're dead or getting it i honestly
feel like you you should yeah because
it's good it's good so with that do
follow us on our socials and subscribe
to the channel
we'll see you guys on the next one adios
[Music]